uh as jans mentioned my name is conor
hookstra
and in today's talk we're going to be
taking a look at c
plus concepts and comparing them to
adjacent
language features in other programming
languages so
um we're going to be taking a look at
haskell type classes rust traits
swift protocols and as a bonus
i also included but this was post my
submission for this talk
d type constraints so let's hop into it
first things first is all of these
slides and
code examples that are presented in this
talk you can find on my github page in
the talks repository
under the meeting c plus uh
2020 folder and the first thing i want
to say
is that i'm not an expert i'm just a
dude so this is a quote from scott sher
who mentioned this in his cppcon 2015
talk
i'm not an expert i'm just a dude so if
you've seen any of my other talks you
might have seen this
uh in my c plus plus uh now
and cppcon 2019 algorithm intuition talk
uh this applies even more here because i
am not a rust swift
haskell or d developer uh i primarily am
a c-plus plus developer
so if you are watching this online in
the future and you are from one of those
languages
and i make a mistake please let me know
but uh no uh
i learned most of uh what i'm presenting
in this talk about the other languages
in the last couple months so about me uh
i'm a senior library software engineer
working for nvidia specifically i work
on the rapids ai team
this is an awesome team we're completely
open source and we're working on
putting the data science pipeline end to
end
on gpus so if you're familiar with the
python pandas library basically we're
taking
uh that library and some other uh
machine learning libraries
and putting them on the gpu so if you're
interested check that out
every month i think we're hitting new uh
record-breaking download numbers
um for us that is so it's a super
exciting uh library to be working on
i'm a programming language enthusiast so
at any given time i'm learning a number
of languages
i love algorithms and beautiful code uh
i'm the organizer
of the programming languages virtual
meetup you can find details for that on
my github as well
and i have a youtube channel and uh
additionally
i'm excited to acknow to announce uh
that
in the next coming weeks i will be
starting a podcast
uh with bryce adelstein-loback so
we have the domain registered and
we have a twitter account set up but we
have yet to record our first episode but
that'll be happening this month
so if you're interested uh by the time
this goes online the recording of this
video
we should have our first episode up it's
going to be called the algorithm
plus data structures equals program
podcast otherwise known as adsp the
podcast
and you can follow us on twitter right
now if you want and this photo was taken
of bryce and i
almost exactly one year ago on november
10
2019 this was taken in dublin
in between the iso belfast meeting and
i believe the fall accu uh
conference so um really looking forward
uh to doing this with bryce so check it
out if you're interested
on to the talk the first thing i want to
say about the talk is that this is not
a language war talk um although i will
be comparing languages
uh this is not like which which
programming language
is uh better than uh the other
programming language
so not a programming uh language war
talk if you've seen any of my other
talks or tweets you'll know that i love
all programming languages
i highlighted this last year at meeting
c 2019
in a lightning talk that i gave called
consistently inconsistent
where i looked at a number of different
programming languages and i pointed out
that we should all be kinder
to our other programming language sort
of developer
quote-unquote nemesis we can learn a ton
from other programming languages
and uh i i really like um programming
languages so just know
if i say anything bad about rest or
swift or haskell or d
uh it's not because i don't like the
language it's just a comparison
um also too this was recently from the
pldi 2020 programming language design
and implementation conference
uh guys guy steele who's one of my
heroes
um he said in an ama that uh he loves
all programming languages too so
i think this is just absolutely
fantastic so once again
uh this is not a language word talk it's
a language comparison talk and
furthermore
um this is part one of part two um and
it's actually uh reduced so i give a
practice version of this talk
and it went 90 minutes so i've had to
cut out about 20 of the content in the
future i hope to give an extended
version
um but know that this is supposed to be
an introduction to these uh
language features this is not supposed
to go into the details about you know
which ones there's no there's no
performance analysis there's no compile
time analysis
this is introducing you to the language
features um how do you use them how do
you write a simple one
and um what do they look like when you
compare them side by side
so with that of the way let's take a
look at our agenda so
the first section which is about uh one
third of the talk
is an introductory our introduction
slash history
um to sort of what i learned about these
different languages
and sort of how i came to give this talk
after that there'll be a short section
on generics and parametric polymorphism
then we're going to look at two examples
the first one is pretty simple the
second one is a little bit more involved
but still pretty simple
and at the end i'll give my final
thoughts on
these different language facilities so
introduction
the start of the path to this talk
um happened in 2018 when i started
learning
learning haskell so this is while i was
at amazon there was a study group and
a few of my co-workers wanted to learn
functional programming so
we started working our way through this
introduction to functional programming a
free online edx course or edx course
that's taught by eric meyer who's a
pretty well known individual in the
programming language community
it was fantastic but at a certain point
we found that we wanted sort of a better
textbook that was than was
recommended in the course so we started
reading real world
haskell and if you've read this book
you'll know that um chapter six focuses
on something called type classes and at
the time i was aware in 2018 that c plus
plus 20
uh was going to be getting concepts um
but i didn't know much about them
and learning about type classes um a
sort of a little you know
light bulb went off in my head that
these might be somewhat similar
uh to c plus 20 concepts that we were
going to get in the future but that i
didn't really think much
uh more of it at the time i just sort of
made a mental note of it
um then roughly uh a year later
i listened to a wwdc talk um
entitled protocol oriented programming
in swift
um and this talk was given by dave
abrahams uh for those of you
that have been in the c plus plus
community for a while you might
recognize that name
and we're going to take a look at a clip
from this talk
of course i'm talking about protocols
protocols have
all these advantages and that's why when
we made swift
we made the first protocol oriented
programming language
[Applause]
so a little bit of an awkward clap there
but uh this was a
um a very very highly reviewed talk i
think it's ranked as like the second
best wwdc talk
on certain top 10 languages or top 10
sort of videos from wwdc
i have to be honest at the time i didn't
know much about swift and i was just
watching it because dave was giving the
talk and i'd seen a couple of his other
talks he's given talks on algorithms
before
but i thought it was an interesting talk
and it seemed like they were making some
pretty cool claims about um
this new sort of protocol oriented uh
programming paradigm that they were
introducing
then just over one month later so this
is at the end of 2019 then in january of
2020 so this is this year now
um i was listening to a podcast called
magic read-along
where the two co-hosts uh said the
following
i just watched a video today on um
swift and it's uh and like their
protocol
driven development or protocol orient
oriented development
and yeah it it's pop i guess there was
protocol oriented programming and
uh they just basically introduced type
classes and they're like we invented
this this is amazing
is it is it actual type classes or is it
just like
uh interfaces it's it's interfaces that
you can extend
uh ad hoc on on the fly like it's a
and basically you can have as many
constraints as you want it's basically
type classes
um so i posted the like 1988 wadler
paper
so this was uh pretty amazing i thought
that just one month previously
i had been watching this talk and then
they were mentioning that type classes
were basically what protocols were in
swift
so i thought this was this was just
awesome uh and then i went and looked up
the 1988 paper which i think i had read
previously
it's a pretty famous paper where uh
philip wadler who's also very well known
uh he's known as lambda man in some
circles if you've watched any of his
talks
this paper introduces type classes um
which is sort of
uh not the first uh you know time this
has been presented it was presented in
i think uh miranda and standard ml and
then even going back to clue from before
uh but this is the paper that
popularized it and led to it um
sort of entering into haskell um so
we'll come back to this paper in a bit
um and and finally on this introduction
sort of path
four days later from uh january 9th of
2020 i was on reddit and i stumbled
across
the following post which says influence
of c plus on swift
and this links to a question on quora
and we're going to go on a small
digression
very quickly because we have a lot to
get through uh but what is the question
on cora so it states what are the
similarities and differences between c
plus plus and swift
uh if i had time i'd ask who do you
thought answered this question but i
don't
um so i'm just going to tell you the
person that has the top answer to this
question is david van der vood um who as
it says in his sort of byline is on the
c plus committee and is one of the five
members of the direction group he's also
uh the well-known author of the c plus
plus templates book that
uh your previous speaker nicholaius is
also a co-author of
and doug greger his name is going to
come up later in the talk and he's the
third co-author so if we take a look at
what david said
we're not going to read all of it but
we'll highlight some things so he says
remember that the original designer of
swift was chris lattner who started and
led the llvm project llvm is written in
c plus plus and the
clang c plus plus compiler is one of the
primary drivers for its continued
development
when it came time to select the lead
swift compiler engineer and lead swift
standard library designer who did apple
turn to
doug greger for the compiler and dave
abrahams for the library both were some
of the main contributors to the to the c
plus 11 standard and widely recognized
as world-class c
plus experts uh so you can see uh chris
lattner at the top there
and then doug greger and dave abrahams
um so pretty interesting or at least i
find this sort of programming language
history uh
interesting and also interesting at the
very bottom it says
uh all that to say that swift was
tremendously influenced by c plus plus
however apple does not acknowledge this
i've been told that it is because more
senior apple decision makers dislike c
plus at a personal level in part because
of the bitter rivalry between c plus
plus and objective c in the 1980s
um so uh that's pretty interesting to
note that
swift i guess due to management doesn't
like to acknowledge it but
i've watched a lot of llvm talks and um
a lot of the folks that are working on
swift
um even if they're not i guess the
management they do widely acknowledge
that they borrow from any languages
including c plus plus
um last note about uh sort of these
folks so we have chris lattner then doug
greger and dave abrahams
um doug grever and dave abrahams this
was before my time sort of joining the c
plus plus community
um were uh very very involved in c plus
plus as the post sort of mentions
so much so that this photo of dave
abraham's is actually of him standing
right next to john cobb
at uh c plus now i believe 2016. and
john kob
i assume most of you are familiar with
but for those of you that aren't he's
the organizer
of cppcon c plus now and he's the
co-host and creator of cppchat so
pretty interesting uh to know all this
sort of trivia and that is the end of
this digression so back to
the reddit post which is where we
started our digression that was
a post about the influence of c plus on
swift and the main thing i want to point
out here
is uh two comments uh or two parts of
comments that were in the reddit thread
so the first thing
it's just the following where uh mr
mobster says swift protocols and rust
traits are very similar
um so i'm not a rust programmer i think
everyone in russ sort of is
uh is knows that uh traits are very
similar to type classes
and protocols but this was the first
time that i was sort of hearing about it
uh furthermore
um in the next post uh mr mobster says
this is why
i am saving are saying that swift
protocols are more similar to rust
traits
and goes on to say and then of course we
have c plus concepts which are very
interesting as well
they are somewhat like traits and
protocols um so
this was sort of the point on january
13th of uh this year 2020
that i decided that i'm going to give a
talk at some point comparing and
learning about these
sort of traits protocols type classes
concepts and then later on d
type constraints to see how they compare
and then in the preparation for this
talk i found a number of other resources
and videos that sort of talked about the
relationship between these so the first
one is a clip from a youtube video by
an individual that goes by context free
online where he says the following
typescript structural interfaces nor on
go interfaces
nor on rush traits nor on swift
protocols
nor on haskell type classes nor on
standard ml modules
instead i'm going to talk about c plus
20 concepts
the next time i heard sort of
comparisons happening was in an llvm
2017 talk
where one of the presenters was john
mccall so swift has
a very powerful generic system a very
powerful system of constrained generics
and those are expressed by what we call
protocols
protocols are a lot like features that
you see in other
languages with first class generic
features such as
signatures in central ml or type classes
in haskell
and if you've been following cpus plus
london's meetup they recently did
two different uh joint sessions with
rust and c-plus plus
and in two of those talks um they both
referred to how concepts are similar to
rust trades so we're not going to watch
that but
this talk by pious our graphs hardin
russ mentions it
and then a friendly introduction to russ
by hendrick uh also mentions it
and then in the most recent rust uh
slash uh c plus plus london meetup
uh james muns uh refers to a talk uh
here there's a really wonderful talk by
marin
um at rust fest in 2016 where he goes
over
the rust that could have been and so
let's take a look at that talk
and then at some points um
we got more haskell people on the team
and we all started agitating for
uh a type class kind of implementation
uh interface thing that we ended up now
so what marin's talking about there is
uh sort of refers to what i heard in
another podcast
functional geekery where the guest said
the following i've been referring to
rust as the love child between haskell
and c plus plus
so potentially this is how we should
think of c plus plus haskell or c
plus plus haskell plus heart but i think
that's kind of interesting just to know
like
what languages have influenced other
languages um so the point of all these
clips
is that there are a number of languages
that have language features that are
similar to the five that we are going to
be looking at today
the five that we're looking at are
concepts from c plus plus uh traits from
russ protocols from swift
type classes from haskell and type
constraints from d but know that these
were influenced
uh by other languages and um languages
have other features that are under
different names like interfaces etc
but we're going to take a look at these
five that are highlighted so moving on
to the second section
uh generics and parametric polymorphism
so at this point we're going to hop back
to the 1988
philip wadler paper so in this paper he
introduces type classes but in the
introduction he also defines
two different types of polymorphism the
first one is ad-hoc polymorphism and the
second one is parametric polymorphism
so let's take a look at those two
definitions the first one
is ad-hoc polymorphism which states
ad-hoc polymorphism occurs when a
function is defined over several
different types
acting in a different way for each type
a typical example
is overloaded multiplication the same
symbol may be used to denote
multiplication for integers such as 3
times 3 and multiplication for floating
point values as in 3.14 times 3.14
so that's interesting to know that we
have sort of same name functions that
have different
behaviors based on the type um whatever
then goes on to define parametric
polymorphism right below this uh so
parametric polymorphism
occurs when a function is defined over a
range of types acting in the same way
for each type
um and the example they go on to show is
length so and you
you can't see it because it's off screen
but it says that uh
length on a list of floating point
numbers versus a list
of integers um has the exact same
behavior
um so there's this sort of analog
between the two definitions ad hoc
polymorphism refers to
sort of same name functions with
different behavior based on different
types whereas parametric polymorphism
um leads to having same name functions
uh
with different types but the same
behavior so why is this important
um c plus sort of has support for
parametric uh polymorphism at least
superficially through its uh templates
facility
um but like why is this important and i
didn't really truly appreciate
um that i i love parametric polymorphism
and templates but i didn't truly
appreciate
it until i learned go and
um before we take a look at this example
let's uh take a look at what kevlin
henney one of my favorite speakers has
to say about go
now here's an interesting one so this is
go which has been described as a very
opinionated language
in terms of its style and its design
decisions many which i find
incredibly easy to disagree with
so interesting for uh kevland henry to
say that i think go is a very
interesting language
but i definitely agree that is super
opinionated but back to the example
um this piece of code uh does not
compile
and i'll pause for a second um
for you to try and figure out why that
is
uh but as there's a bit of a leg and i'm
short i have a lot to cover
um i'm not going to ask the audience
i'll just give you a couple seconds
and by now some of you might have
figured it out it's because the math.min
function uh
only works for floats so go famously
does not have support for parametric
polymorphism
um and that is super irritating
in my opinion because in order to get
this piece of code to work
uh for integers that is like without
changing a and b
to floats uh you have to cast a
to a float64 then b to a float64 get
back a float64 from math.min
and then cast that back to an int if you
want it to be an int um
so parametric polymorphism uh or any
facility that superficially gives you
support for that
um is something that i really really uh
desire
in the programming language that i'm
working in um just a note so this used
to be a video clip i'm not going to play
it like i said i'm short on time
but philip wadler the individual i
mentioned earlier from the 1988 type
classes paper
rob pike that one of the designers of go
has reached out to phil
and asked him to help add parametric
polymorphism to
go 2.0 so if you're a go developer
and you are hoping that uh parametric
polymorphism gets them to go that might
be coming in the future
so parametric polymorphism uh is really
important in my opinion
um and one last thing while we're in
this sort of generics and parametric
polymorphism um
brief uh overview is this paper uh
that was written for uh introducing or
suggesting an introduction of
lightweight parametric polymorphism
polymorphism for oberon which is a
language um
uh created i believe by nicholas verth
who is more popular for
uh past pascal and modula um one two and
three
um the reason i'm highlighting this
paper is because there's a fantastic
quote um that i've heard from someone
that i can't remember
but the quote is the following we
introduced parametric polymorphism via
our previous example
a type may be parameterized on types
in much the same way as a procedure may
be parameterized
on values and this is my mental model
for what concepts and adjacent
language features similar to concepts
are
you can think of type constraints or
concepts or insert whatever you call it
in your language
as the way that types are to values
so types define the set
of values uh that uh
integer or a floating point can assume
so when you have an integer it can be 0
1 2 3 4 when you have a floating point
you can have numbers with fractional
parts so a type defines sort of the set
of values
uh that the type uh the values can
assume
uh a type constraint does the same thing
for types
um or a type class or a concept you're
basically
uh defining the set of values that your
type can take
um and i've been told that this mental
model is wrong
but i think that's totally okay because
i heard once before that all models are
wrong but some are useful
and i find this mental model very useful
so that takes us through the first two
sections of sort of introducing us to
uh you know how did i get to giving this
talk um what is parametric polymorphism
and now we're going to take a look at
our first example so
we've gotten through about half of our
slides and we're going to slow down and
take a look at code now
which i think is sort of where you're
going to learn what concepts look like
and all the other protocols traits type
classes
and type constraints so our first
example
is the following we are going to
add two integers pretty simple um but i
think it's quite illustrative to look at
taking a non-generic function and making
it generic and what that looks like in
these five
different languages so in c plus plus we
have the following
uh hopefully everybody that's watching
this either live or online
uh on youtube in the future is familiar
with this syntax so here we're using
trailing return type that's maybe the
only thing that might be
somewhat surprising to certain
individuals but otherwise we're taking
two integers a and b and then just
returning them
so we're going to move this code a
little bit around and then take a look
at what the
uh same code looks like in d rus swift
and haskell so in d we have the
following
um it is almost exactly identical to the
c plus plus solution
and could be exactly identical if i
wasn't using trailing return type in the
c
plus solution the only difference here
being that d
does not support trailing return type so
you have to put the uh return type
uh before the function name um which is
fine
um rust uh looks slightly different so
here
uh they have a keyword uh uh for
sort of declaring that you're uh
declaring a function
then we have uh a colon b colon
for our arguments to our function i32
instead of int
and then trailing return type plus just
a plus b so note that there's no
semicolon here and no return
rest does have semicolons and returns uh
a return keyword
but for functions in russ you can omit
the semicolon and the return
if the last expression is what you're
returning and that's pretty idiomatic to
do in rust
um swift looks pretty similar
except that instead of fun we have funk
so two extra characters um and we have
uh
ince with a capital i instead of i32 um
and then we have sort of the underbar
which is for uh argument names i won't
get into that it's just something that
swift supports you can omit those in
uh swift 5.3 but on the online
playground that i was using 5.1 you
still
have to um put the under on the bar
there um
and note that uh trailing return type
and a plus b as well you can omit the
return and the semicolon
and uh last but not least is
haskell one of my favorite languages
this is going to look extremely
different
if you're not familiar with haskell here
we don't have any keyword to define
that we're creating a function because
everything in haskell basically is a
function
and the way you can think of the the
first line is that after the double
colon
the first two integers are the arguments
to our function
and the last one is our output this
isn't actually what's happening but in
terms of coming from c
plus plus and trying to understand the
type signature that's the way you can
think about it
um and then a and b are sort of the
names for our arguments and then we're
just adding them together
um so to sort of summarize the
differences between
all of the following five we can put
them at the top
uh reorient them so so we sort of align
the function names the trailing return
types and the bodies of the function
except for haskell because it's so
different to the other four
and then we can summarize the
differences here so keyword before the
function
uh i posted this or something similar to
this that we're gonna look at a second
on twitter and then
i got a bunch of comments saying oh auto
is how you make a function
uh i can use auto for variables i can
use auto etc etc my point here is that
uh if you want to use trailing return
type the keyword that goes before your
function is auto
um for d it's the type for rust it's fun
for swift it's funk
and for haskell it doesn't have one
what are integers called or at least for
32-bit integers in c plus it's int or in
32 underscore t
uh d is int rust is i-32 and swift
and haskell are int capital i uh
trailing return type the only language
that doesn't
support it is d and is the return
necessary
only in uh c plus plus and uh d the
other three it is not so
as i mentioned we're going to go on a
small digression here and look at
uh way more languages than just these
five when it comes to the keyword
uh before uh a function name
um so note that this isn't entirely
accurate um
for closure technically d fun is a macro
um some languages have uh two keywords
that you can use for functions
so we'll zoom in and take a closer look
um the top one
is def uh from the following languages i
think the most interesting language here
is crystal
for those of you that haven't heard of
crystal crystal is basically
uh ruby plus c it's basically designed
to have the syntax of ruby
and the speed of c and it's a statically
compiled ruby so if you know anything
about ruby it's uh dynamically
uh i don't think it's compiled
interpreted language um
but so crystal's just supposed to be a
fast uh a fast ruby basically with the
speed of c
um note that fortran also has another
keyword called subroutine i believe
um but yeah pretty interesting we scroll
down
uh we can see that function's the the
next most popular
then funk which go nim and swift have
nim's an interesting language
um and it has two keywords as well
proc is the other one and funk actually
is a keyword
uh for defining functions without side
effects so nim is like a low level
language similar
um to other languages like zig and
crystal
and uh neat that they have a keyword for
side effect-free functions i wish more
languages had that kind of thing
um then after funk we have fun which
exists in rust and zig
and then at the bottom we have um the
languages that are sort of one-offs
fun is for kotlin which i think is a i
think that's a nice keyword if i wrote a
language i might choose fun
end of our digression and uh back to our
uh functions that add to integers so
what we're going to do now
is we are going to take these
non-generic functions
and make them generic one by one
so in c plus probably most of you know
how to do this
and that's by adding a template so you
get rid of the
explicit ins and you write template
angle
type name t angle and then you replace
each of the ins with a t
and you now have a generic function uh
pretty cool
in d it's something very similar uh
we are going to instead of adding uh
angles and a couple new keywords
we're just going to oh i skipped the
head so uh in c plus plus 20
we actually have the ability now to omit
the template uh and the type name and
just explicitly
put autos in here and i think this is
super nice i'm not sure if it's gonna
become like against
best practice uh only time will tell um
but uh i think this is really really
cool and it's i think more general than
any of the other
languages d does something similar
but minus two keywords so it instead of
using angles uses extra parentheses
after
add so the first set of parentheses now
that contains the t
is for uh the template type and then
once again you just replace
int with ttt and uh we're good to go
here
uh for rest we have to do the following
so
add um angle t angle and then replace
each of the ins
uh with a t so you're starting to see a
pattern here
uh for swift we're gonna do the exact
same thing we're gonna replace
uh each of the ins with the t and then
put angle t
angle in front of our parentheses and
haskell
as maybe one of the more interesting
ones you just replace each of the ins
uh with a lowercase letter typically
idiomatically you would use a here but
in order to be uh you know symmetric to
the other examples i'm using t
um however not all of these
pieces of code work um
and i'll pause maybe i'll maybe i'll ask
and see how far
uh people are behind
does anybody know which ones don't work
i've paused but i don't see the chat
updating so i think there's a bit of a
lag
so the answer to the question uh for the
ones that do work
are the first two c plus plus and d
all the other functions don't work
um and this is because the model uh
of that generics uses uh is
almost the opposite from a certain
perspective
um so for rust in order to get this to
work
we have to specify something that lets
uh the compiler know
that a and b are addable um so the way
that you do that
is by adding the following basically
adding a
quote unquote constraint on type t that
says t is
edible for swift we do something very
similar
um we call this uh t numeric
and anything that's numeric can be added
and
uh for haskell we are going to do uh
something very similar to swift and russ
as well by adding a type class
that lets us know that uh t is
numeric as well um and this
is one of i think the most important
points of this talk that i want to
get across to the watchers and listeners
it is that amongst these language
features
there are two categories the categories
names that i'm choosing are type
constraints versus type classes so like
note obviously type classes are what
haskell call
calls their language feature rust has
trade swift has protocols
um but i think that this is
at least this is the way that i think
about it so type constraints
are the language features that actually
constrain
you're starting with the world and then
restricting what you can do with your
types
so in the previous five examples that we
looked at
you know c plus plus and d you didn't
need to let the compiler know anything
about your generic type t
you could just go ahead write the code
and it would work
but for haskell rust and swift just
writing a generic type t
um doesn't doesn't let you do anything
with it
um you have to let the compiler know and
therefore like give consent
to uh add to your two generic types
um a and b which both are the same in
this example t but in other
examples they could be something else
and to highlight this even further let's
take a look at a function
that takes a generic type t and returns
a generic type t
so we'll take a look at c plus plus and
haskell
and this is the how you would write
those functions in each of the languages
so
for c plus we have template type name t
a function f that takes a single
argument t
and returns a t and haskell
is the same thing here it's a lot more
uh terse though we have our function f
that takes a single t
and returns a single t um and the point
that i'm trying to make here is that c
plus plus
with this function we can we can do
anything
um the way you write it it might not end
up compiling um
but we don't need to do anything more uh
to t in order to write whatever function
that you want to write
whereas with haskell it's the exact
opposite we can do exactly one thing
with this function
and that's just return the t that we got
because we don't we don't know how to do
we don't know if we can compare t to
something we don't know if we can add t
to something
we don't know anything about t um and
and this is like
it's completely opposite uh and uh
interestingly there's a name for this
function i'm sure
anyone that's a functional programmer uh
or has spent some time with functional
programming languages knows the name of
it it is
uh id in haskell which stands for
identity
and interesting note in c plus 20 we're
getting a function object
in the functional header um called uh
identity that does the exact same thing
this might seem useless but it actually
comes in handy
many times if you start doing sort of
functional programming things
um but i'm not going to jump into that
because we still have
quite a few slides to get through so um
i think this is really interesting like
once i sort of observe that this was the
differing behaviors between type
constraints and type classes
because of the way that the type class
category refers to their generics
if you recall earlier from the llvm 2017
talk when john mccall who is
i believe the main implementer of
generics and swift
this was the start of that video clip
they refer to their generics that use
protocols
as constrained generics and
an unconstrained generic is one
that you can't do anything with um which
i find
completely counter-intuitive i had
someone recently
try to explain that potentially you're
constraining
uh what your type can be and therefore
increasing
uh the possible things that you can do
with your type
but that i still think that's
counterintuitive because you're sort of
jumping through a mental hoop in order
to make sense of the way that you're
speaking about something from like the c
plus perspective you actually you are
constraining like it is
uh a concept is a constraint on your
generic type you're limiting what you
can
um pass into a generic function when you
put a concept on it
where it's the opposite in other
languages um furthermore in this same
presentation
uh or i think it was even earlier um it
refers to
uh the parametric polymorphism that
swift has as
bounded parametric polymorphism um so
this is why i sort of i split this talk
into two talks this one's just an
introduction but i started going through
the literature
and um in the literature it seems like
there's zero agreement on what they
refer to this kind of parametric
polymorphism that has constraints
or has bounds um some of the papers
refer to it as bounded parametric
polymorphism some of them refer to it
as a constrained parametric polymorphism
um
other papers uh come up with sort of uh
different names that i think refer to
what i'm sort of referring to as type
constraints versus type classes as like
nominal and structural
but these were like you know 30 to 80
page papers that i did not have the time
to like fully digest and understand
um so just note that there are
subcategories of parametric polymorphism
and uh the naming at least to me is a
little bit counter-intuitive
but as long as you have the mental model
to keep things this way where you've got
type constraints that are actually
constraining the generic type such that
it's limiting what you can pass to the
function
versus type classes which you start with
a generic function and then have to add
constraints in order to give your
function the ability to do something
with the generic type
and that's the point that i'm trying to
drive across with this example
so this brings us to our last example
which is a little bit more involved
and this is uh looking at
shapes so specifically we're going to
implement
objects classes a circle and a rectangle
and then we're going to write a
non-generic print shape
info function and then we're going to
make that uh
we're going to constrain that
non-generic function by first making it
generic
and then adding either a concept or a
trait or a protocol
or a type class or a type constraint to
each of these now generic functions
and we're going to write that concept or
insert language feature ourselves to see
what that looks like
so first we're going to start off with c
plus and this is what our
circle class and rectangle class look
like in c
plus um so this uh i have mixed feelings
about um
note here that we've got uh for our
circle a single member variable r
which stands for radius and uh in
rectangle we have
two variables w and h for width and
height i'm just shortening them because
it's slide where so if you're unhappy
with the formatting
or anything on the slides note this is
just slidewear
to try and make this all fit and
we've got three methods name area and
parameter all of these are non-modifying
methods
so in c plus in order to make that
happen or to ensure that that's the case
we have to put const after each of these
um using trailing return type and
probably the coolest thing
in my opinion about this code is that
it's making use of c plus plus 20
constants with the use of pi in our two
area and perimeter
functions so nothing too exciting here
if you're a veteran c
plus developer moving on to the
d version of this code so very similar
we've switched
to a pascal case for our class names
because that's idiomatic and d
um the main difference here is that our
constructor doesn't have the same name
as our class
it now has the name this um and uh
we have no trailing return type um
everything else is almost identical um
including that we have to add const
after our method in order to make it
um uh non-modifying and i think that's a
mistake d had the opportunity to get the
default
right there and um yeah it's unfortunate
that they
they copied c plus plus when it came to
that um moving on to our rust example
uh this is gonna be starting to look a
little bit different than what we've
seen but still
um still pretty parsable if you're a c
plus plus developer
so note that in your struct circle and
rectangle you define the members
and then for your member functions you
define them in an impulse scope
so here we've got our name area and
perimeter methods uh trailing return
type as well
f32 similar to the i32 for our floating
point number
uh a big difference here is that uh for
our string literals you have to call the
dot to string method in order to
get this to compile and we've also got
some extra selfs
but note that you don't see const
anywhere one i don't believe
rust has the constant keyword they have
the opposite of const which is mutt
so by default everything is cons so
these methods are by default
non-modifiable and i think that's a
fantastic language decision
if you want them to be modifiable you
have to add a mutt in front of the self
that you're passing
to each of these methods moving on to
the swift
example which is very similar to the
rust
once again they made the correct in my
opinion language decision of making by
default
methods of classes non-modifying in
order to make the name area perimeter
modifying you have to add the mutable
keyword
um other than that though it's pretty
straightforward note that their
constructor is called
uh init and uh
we have trailing return type as well
here and i think it's pretty
straightforward honestly i found
swift i make this point at the end of
the top but swift
as a c plus developer you can basically
just like guess your way to programming
the correct thing
um i found swift an extremely pleasant
language
uh to code in because of several reasons
that i'll talk about at the end but yeah
it was very easy writing this up
last but not least we have haskell so
haskell is going to look
obviously the most different here i'm
using i believe record syntax and then
just
six free functions note that
this actually doesn't work because i use
the what looks like function overloading
that doesn't actually exist
in haskell so the functions name area
and perimeter
have to be named differently in order
for this code to compile so
unfortunately i have to name these
circle name circle area circle perimeter
and then the same thing for rectangle
note this isn't the best way to do this
there are you know
probably 10 different ways you can write
this code the reason i'm writing it this
way
is so that it lends itself to converting
it to the type class code that we're
going to see
in a few slides here so know that you
know obviously this isn't very elegant
code
i'm just setting up the transition to
the type class code
in the future um and so now let's go
back to c
and we're going to look at the generic
print shape info functions
uh for each of these uh examples
so we're starting off with c plus so
here back to snake case because that's
idiomatic in c
plus we have print shape info and using
the auto keyword instead of the template
type name
with c plus plus 20 and uh although the
compilers and uh library devs haven't
implemented a standard format yet you
can still use it on godbolt so i'm using
format to just get ready because it's
coming and
this is pretty straightforward so this
this works if you call this on both
uh our rectangle and circle class this
will compile and work
and that's fantastic moving on to the d
example we have print shape info
now in camelcase because it's a function
and this looks slightly different but
it's pretty straightforward and similar
to what we saw
in the adding integer examples so we're
using these parentheses
to declare our generic type t
and then um just calling name area and
perimeter similar to what we did in the
c plus plus example and
similar to c plus plus this also works
due to the fact that we are in the type
constraint model and so
we have no constraints therefore it
works with everything that compiles
um which is which is nice uh
and now we're gonna move to the three
languages that don't currently work
so print shape info back to snake case
here
interestingly the compiler will actually
uh like whine at you
if you don't do this in snake case if
you do it and which is what i did
initially i did it in camelcase
and then the compiler said it's not
idiomatic uh please switch to snake case
um anyways we have our angle t angle for
our generic type t
um however this isn't constrained at
this point in time um
so if you try to compile this you're
gonna get the following
name method not found in t and so
we're going to have to fix this by
setting up a trait and we're going to do
that in a second
note that uh i had a digression about
this that i had to take out but
i just still want to briefly mention the
compiler messages in rust
are mind-blowingly helpful um it's it
reads here items from traits can only be
used if the type parameter is bounded by
the trait the following trait defines an
item name
perhaps you need to restrict the type uh
parameter t with it
and then it gives you a suggestion for
the exact trait that you need to use
in order to get this to compile and in
my digestion i showed like four other
examples where the compiler just tells
you
exactly what you need in order to get
the code to compile and as someone
exploring the language
that is like it's an amazing story and
an amazing experience so like kudos to
the rust compiler team
fantastic work there moving on to the
swift print shape info
here this looks like almost identical to
the d code
but once again similar to rust this is
not going to compile because we need to
constrain our generic in order to get
this to work
um so if you try and compile this you're
going to get a value of type t
has no member name um and moving on to
the haskell example
i could have written something here um
but the goal i was trying to show
is like working your way towards a
generic function that works
and um going towards type classes
doesn't really have a middle step it's
either going to work in haskell
so it isn't or it isn't um so i left
this slide out
but we are going to get this code
working uh when we circle back to this
so
for the final time we're going to go
back to c plus and work our way through
these examples once more
uh by adding the code that we need for
concepts
uh type constraints uh protocols traits
and type classes so we're back in c plus
plus we have our
currently compiling print shape info
generic function
but now we want to constrain this so
we're going to write a concept
so this is what that's going to look
like um the first thing that we need to
do
is to declare a string concept because
we need to have a concept
for the return type of our name function
and currently the standard library
doesn't provide you
a string concept once we have that we
can define another concept shape
and we do this by going template type 9s
concept shape equals requires and then
your parameter s
and then embraces all of the
requirements that you
want for your concept so for our concept
we want
it to basically have three methods name
area and perimeter
and we want the return type for each of
those to be string and floating point
number
so this is pretty nice it in my opinion
isn't as elegant as the other languages
but
the other languages don't have 40 years
of legacy um so considering that
c plus has 40 years of legacy um i think
that this is pretty nice
um and once we have this concept all we
have to do
is add shape in front of auto and now we
have a
conceptified generic function or
constrained generic function
note that there are two or three or
maybe even four different
ways to write this you can um in your
template type name replace type name
with shape
and there's a couple of different ways
to do it um without there being best
practice at the moment this is my
favorite way to do it
i think it looks the cleanest but note
that there are what other ways that you
can get this
working with that we're going to move on
to the uh d
example so for d to write a type
constraint you have to do the following
um so it's a little bit noisy we have
uh template shape parent paren uh then
braces and then inside that
uh const the name of our uh type
constraint shape
and then double underbar traits with the
bit of noise compiles
comma and then our generic type and then
once we have that another set of braces
and then inside here we basically set up
the methods that we want our shape to
have note
i didn't spend time trying to figure out
how to constrain the return type so this
one's a bit looser than what we just saw
in c plus plus concepts but it still
does the trick so
this is going to be a cons or i should
say type constraint
shape um that is met
i just got a warning asking me if i
would like to restart my computer
i'm going to say no and
it's going to any any class that has the
name area or perimeter
method is going to conform to this um
and uh
similar to what we did for c plus
concepts now that we have
our type constraint um we just need to
modify our function it looks a little
bit different so here we're using
an if statement or expression not
exactly sure which one it is
and then going shape exclamation mark
and then passing the generic that we are
constraining here and
i actually like this quite a bit um it's
very very readable in my opinion
um like you need to know the c plus uh
concept syntax
to parse that uh a concept goes before
auto in a parameter list
um this though even if you have no no
idea what um
d looks like you might be able to make
an educated guess of
of what uh the if statement is doing
here
um so now we're moving on to rust
um i'm showing here the impul circle and
rectangle because we're gonna need to
make adjustments to those lines of code
in order to get this to work
um but for russ we're gonna uh define a
trait now so trait
um has some pretty nice syntax in my
opinion uh we go trait shape uh braces
and then uh our three methods uh that we
want our trait um
to have and note that if i go back one
step
we also made a change where it said
impulse circle and imple rectangle
before
it now says impulse shape for circle and
impulse shape for a rectangle
and similar once we have our trait now
all we need to do in order to get this
to be a compiling rust piece of code
is to add the colon shape on our generic
type t in the angle brackets
and now we have uh constraints or
constrained
our generic type t and this example will
compile now
so i think this is like really really
clean i really like
the way that rust has designed this uh
moving on to swift we have our
class rectangle and class circle once
again because we're going to need to
make adjustments to these two lines of
code
and uh we have to implement a protocol
now so
protocols in my opinion are probably the
cleanest
i'm not sure why but the lack of
semicolons just makes this look
really really nice in my opinion so it's
almost identical to traits though other
than that we've got protocol shape
and then our three methods name area and
perimeter
that returns strings and uh two floats
and note that once again the change that
we make to uh
rectangle and circle is that we're
putting a colon shape
after each of it so this looks similar
to what we know in c plus pluses
inheritance note that these are not the
same things
and then once again now that we have our
protocol on swift all we need to do
is add colon shape to our generic type t
and the angle brackets and we now have a
constrained generic function
which enables this piece of code to
compile
and last but not least we have
our haskell example um so in haskell
we have our circle and rectangle methods
or
circle and rectangle records and note
that i've gone back to the
functions that are named the same and
that because
it leads to a better animation for the
next slide which
is the following so now we have a type
class
shape at the top of the file that
implements
name area and perimeter or i should say
has doesn't implement
and it comes with the function
signatures for each of these
and then for the records we don't have
to change anything so those look
identical
and then we have two pieces of code
instant shape circle wear
and instance shape rectangle where and
these are the
implementations of the three methods or
functions i should say
that adhere to our shape type class this
is pretty nice in my opinion
note that there's a different way that
you can write this where you declare
a sum type that is sort of either a
circle or a rectangle and then you can
combine the two instance
shape for the sum type instead of
splitting these up
but once again just sort of to stay as
closely symmetric to the other examples
this is the way that i'm showing it
so that is a sort of whirlwind tour
of the five different language features
c plus
concepts d type constraints
rust traits swift protocols and haskell
type classes
how you use them and how you can write
sort of the simplest versions
of these in each of their corresponding
languages
and if we want to you might be thinking
that this code
looks a little bit more verbose
currently on the slide that's because we
actually have
a little bit of extra code compared to
the other examples so we can remove
the records and the function
implementations
and then it looks more similar to the
previous examples that we had in the
other four languages
and with roughly uh five or six minutes
left this brings us to
our conclusions so final thoughts um
about just generally going through the
process of writing these examples in
each of the five languages
um they're sort of like fluffy uh things
to
to think about but um they're things
that you know impact
um how much i'm enjoying a language or
not um so the first thing is time to
implement
uh surprisingly c plus plus actually
took me the longest even though it's the
one that i have the most experience in
um swift was incredibly easy like i said
half the time i was just writing the
code and it worked
d is very very similar uh to c plus but
they had a lot more support
for their type constraints so in c plus
plus probably one of the reasons i had
it took longer is that i had to write
the string concept
and the corresponding is string trait
type trait those didn't exist so i had
to write them on my own whereas every
other language i didn't have to worry
about that
and then rust and haskell were in third
and fourth haskell's got a pretty steep
learning curve and
typically to get code working it takes a
little bit longer but once it is working
uh you have a lot more guarantees that
it is going to work and you could
probably say the same thing about rust
um the other metric or one of the other
metrics that i i
measured was lines of code um
unsurprisingly if you're familiar with
haskell code
haskell was the shortest um then swift
and rust
uh and then d and c plus plus c plus
plus and last place once again probably
because
of the um concepts for
string and uh is string type trait um
also d
and c plus plus had uh imports and
includes which added to the line count i
did my best to you know
have uh equal or fair comparison but i'm
sure you know it's plus or minus like
five lines
so take this with a grain of salt um and
the last thing that i sort of
ranked was uh what i call pleasantness
um now i don't want you to think that i
didn't enjoy writing the c
plus code this is a relative comparison
um
swift was just an incredibly pleasant
language to code in coming from c plus
plus
um like i said earlier half the time i
just guessed right i just wrote code
hit run and it worked um and i kept on
like oh
like that worked on the first try
without me having to even go to the
docks like it's
an amazing uh experience chris lattener
um
really focused on something that he
wanted to be one of the values of swift
which
i'm calling pdoc which stands for
progressive disclosure of complexity
this has also been referred to
making the language infinitely hackable
where
you start off having swift feel like
python so you can just go
into the playground type print hello
world exactly like you would in python
and it works but as you want you can
go and look at the more complicated
parts of the language and turn off the
automatic reference counting and and get
really into the weeds if you want
but it's it progressively happens so it
starts off like python and it can end up
feeling like
a more complicated language like c or c
plus plus um but only if you want to and
i i think
uh chris lattiner did a really good job
with that
and uh the defaults are all correct in
my opinion at least the ones that i
experienced
which is really really nice rust uh
compiler messages were amazing which
made it
a very pleasant experience um and for
this language the defaults were also all
correct at least the ones that i ran
into
um d was really similar to c plus but
like i said they have a lot more support
for
sort of generics um and this kind of
thing so it was a little bit easier to
get things working
um however i think that they might have
added a little bit too much complexity
in some
places like we have the const keyword um
they added a bunch like immutable etc
um and i'm not sure i don't know enough
about d but
i'm not sure that that was necessary and
they might have made some mistakes there
um haskell is a steep learning curve um
and the compiler messages are pretty bad
especially when you compare them to rust
so even if rust is
the combination of hassle and c plus
plus um definitely rust did not adopt
the bad compiler messages which i'm very
very thankful for
and uh c plus is at the bottom but
that's not because i think like
like i said i think the code um for what
c
plus is looked potentially as good as it
could look but when you have 40 years of
history
um you're going to end up with less
elegant code when you're starting from
you know
scratch i think swift was introduced in
2014
and rust uh was started by graden horror
in 2010 and then the mozilla team picked
up
and really started rolling in 2012 to
like 15. uh but both of these languages
are less than a decade old like so
that's we're looking at
like close to an order of magnitude of
uh
tenure when compared to c plus um
another thing about c plus plus is most
of the defaults are wrong uh which is
just
it's just a legacy thing you know um
it's not the end of the world but it
would just be nice if i didn't have to
write constant all the time
and i could just write mutt uh when i
wanted something to be mutable
and the other thing is that c plus plus
20 is a work in progress so um
the compilers don't all have full
support for c plus 20. so potentially by
the time
a decade's gone by and we're using cpu
26 um
this is going to be a you know c plus
plus could be at the top of this list
um probably not but it should be a
better story in a little bit time
very quickly um on sort of the
popularity of languages
there's a really cool website by
contextfree from we saw one of the
videos earlier
that ranked c plus uh or here c plus
swift russ haskell and d
are all ranked you can see the number
across all programming languages so c
plus is five swift 15 russ 17 haskell 33
and d73
um it's uh unfair because obviously c
plus has been around for decades but i
just like i think it's fun to look at
these graphs
um you always have to take it with a
grain of salt because they're based on
things that you know aren't always
entirely accurate this one i think is an
average
of a bunch of other websites so on the
next slide i have uh
other language rankings tiob pypl
redbunk and google trends
so roughly they're always in the same
order swift surprisingly
um ranks very very highly i think as
someone that doesn't have an iphone
and a mac and is outside of the apple
ecosystem
i underestimated the size of like the
swift community
when you take a look at the
number of followers on these subreddits
swift falls behind rust here but i think
that's because swift is not the first
place that
swift developers go i think they go to
swift forums i couldn't find a number
for the number of developers
there but i wouldn't be surprised if
that number
uh especially when combined with the
reddit users uh was higher than the russ
one and
um i think this metric is actually more
telling than the other graphs because
given that c plus plus has only been or
it's been around for 40 years and
rust and swift are so new it's amazing
like how many people
are on those uh subreddits um
so once again these are my final
thoughts uh i think all these languages
have their sort of pros and cons
but i think knowing sort of the
different categories of type classes
versus type constraints
and um sort of how the language defaults
are different is
is really cool and i hope that going
through this or watching me go through
this
you learned something and uh you're now
more excited
about using c plus plus concepts in the
future i think it's going to be an
amazing feature to be able to constrain
your generic parameters and make our
compiler messages better and make our
compound times less
all of those things are awesome so i'm
super excited for c plus plus 20
concepts
once again all my slides are on uh my
github under the talks repo
just look for meeting c 2020. um all of
the
podcasts video links papers and other
articles
that i referred to in my talk and didn't
refer to in my talk but used in
preparing for this
you can find in that repo if you're
interested and
with that thank you